welcome committee 11
[Music]
dec of existing
license Victoria
Warehouse
631 um now this is an ajed meeting from
the
on theth
October um can we confirm that we've
seen sight of the late
submissions on
Friday so just introduce
theing
coun coun
Thomas
l
asses and safety consult
AC M
counc natal ow in governance offic
Trafford
Council the gentleman on the right his
letter we got traffic material very L on
we ask
gentl
resp
yes Peter bfield en Health officer deal
with control
matters enviral Health
Officer
James of the
respons thank
you um Mr James par presenting the
riew responsible
Au off respons
auth um
Mr is representing AMG to vior warehouse
and again people
in as
required um
so trct first
the and then will
ask
[Music]
question
ask
your submission ask
questions
submission so following this both
parties some we the meeting make a
decision
um make clear theet isn't my intention
to call although they are here if you
wish to ask
questions far as my concern um but the
Witnesses are here should you should you
to hear I'm also conscious that the sub
commmittee
is
last's
observations
uh in
for um the background to this matter uh
is that the responsible authorities are
concerned to ensure promotion of the
licing injectives and to ensure
thater and
Security in this particular case um
history of enforcement visits goes back
to 9th of June
2019 when n first visited the pris and
witnessed a of control of the people
cure for an event and when being
dispersed thereafter there was in her
inheritance
instru my vehicles using the traffic war
and EnV fa in this country there is of
course not only from the risk of
accident but also the activities of
those who would seek
to there was
no the restrictions were listed which
enable to re
of September
202 the event that took place that night
was observed
by in Rel to
manag
oberved on
sep it is
stop
more if we find system is not
used
and the premises holder scheduled an
event the 21st of September
2021 which coincided with a football be
played at
thej Manchester
United that the adjacent
carare was not available in consequence
Mr made inquir
to man
toldt
enfor inevita
enforce there is right of appeal
enforcement noce which
employ and have
theend
noce in this case Mr
[Music]
cober
for it is important to note that the
notice of is not is being received by
the tri and although the rules provide
the tribunal want it is received in send
a copy to
it a letter was produced on behalf of
the LIC suggesting appear London and
soueast
employ although the letter did not have
a case number or anything else that was
capable of linking that the
oer
2021 it should Beed that the employment
trial has hearing cent in Manchester
and traff is also have twoes
situated when asked about meeting during
meeting to arrange to
discuss I could offer no explanation why
nothing has come that whether or not it
has been listed other than to say he was
not pres
to several conclusions could be drawn
most
obvious perhaps most generous
interet is Prem LIC done nothing to
ensure progress and as we now nothing
has been done to
Def
CC as you
from M continu to attempt to work
premis however the issues were not being
address espe
by
[Music]
given of
open to do all
necessary been
Ed
Mees
specified exceeds theut section 21 31
the health and safety work 1974 namely
to ensure the safe for all people attend
EV on the 15th of September
2022 premis LIC Prem C which is
office Rush premes very
sadly it is against that history of what
the responsible
Authority blind Andy their obligations
of health and safy work
Andy ref listen to resp
warnings
Mak
practices
enforcement authorities you must
consider whether they have capacity and
ability to ensure public safy because if
they do not no
conditions have any possibility ofid
simar before you make that decision it's
appropiate to
consider may be
capable
has
Li the first event was in May 2002 when
the general
manager Chang the
left repl
Mr Mr Taylor became designated princial
supervisor which he
remains today's day on the 6th of
February 2023
2023 the premises were once more on that
occasion there are a number of causes
for concern they an of water in the
premises mil purposes of clean which
amounted to the food safety hygi
regulations
2013 the health and
safety4 there was no water
to no water all there was no hot water
within the medical facility in
circumstances where noed for three hours
during EV the floor in the medical room
was dirt and required deep cleaning or
CL there was inadequate infection
controls and sta sitting on
with there is inadequate evidence as to
how premises license holder had
calculated maximum capacity of each Prem
was ensuring
maximum the designated PR supervisor
this resp EMA poting out be
seen on the 7th February
2023 feary four days after the event
been have been made since the visit to
Ure to construct Wasing
stations
similarly as a result of license holders
the hot water system in ven had a that
prevented it from producing sufficient
hot water during
time Arrangements be made in so far as
the are concerned Mr explained some atts
have been damaged during recent shows
and find adequate washing facilities so
wash water Sy there was an insurance and
additional concerns about the state of
food reparation are
had been remed and the floor of medical
room been de place in far as management
of sh and de was concerned Mr was told
on day visit company was currently
working on putting together remark
carries the inflence although these
areas were been used there was no plan
to managing at all the concern of
responsibility authorities all these
dets the of have been obvious reason
and
haveed
the
Mr for example
ta ear shows that the
question Pro the knowled those defs
exist
and
simple
the same consideration
appes to
be febrary
expect on the 20th of February
2023 in response to
email
feary it wasn't considered to but it
didn't take account of any individual
arrs
should
be
Mr email feary that heal ccul to
demonstr the
wasable days those culations were not
received time and Sugg what maxity each
supp they did not establish
basis with an EMA the 2
M work Carri out
reling
issues the
onear been
awarded on the 6 of February
2023 in
one means major
Improvement what is evid about
it's not clear
necessary the email 21st of also includ
wa EV and having been submitted to Al
for advice Council structural matters
they were found to be inadequate and
further information requ requested in
the absence of response Chas emails
wasent on the 17th of May 2003 the 19th
of
june3
2003 the concern responsibility
responsible
authori the premises managers should
have been that the premises were safe
and fit for purpose before staging any
and all individual events that was done
responsibilities authorities concerned
were real under in
report on 16th of a
exhibit on of
the from 660 person to 25
personate check to under that PR once
small the question how long Prem
managers
would by 660 people before it was able
to ensure that the area was safe on the
23rd of August 2023 a further
enforcement took place to because the
TV on that occasion there was no
football Tak in place
Place
car Manchester United the attend
officers requested specific safy risk
assessment they were not produced the
offic were told they were being Red by
Live Nation separate company to the
premises license holder but one that is
CL me in order to demonstrate effective
plan risk
assessments risk assessments conducted
before so to get this in so far as
possible they should have been on sign
the failure to do that was unaccept and
fail the docents were provided
were deal with medical provided but only
considered risk as far as provided staff
concerned not risk of V staff or the
attending the event the medical those
attending Medical of the site expressed
the vi enforcement officers that they
been moved from their usual position to
new location it was casualty should
inci the other documents provided have
been completed by an external security
company they were not specific and did
not
address during this visit T
remember supervisor told the officers
that a building control certificate for
changeing use of building have been
found f
inquir work not subject completion
certificate
notations
considerate
consequence the use of the first until
such time the appropiate assessments
been carried
out
respons was not
to it was time later
that calculations were provided which
the
submit to establish the use of
that has been aced by the
council the issue that is currently
outstanding which is before the employ
Tri is whether or not that notice should
be canell or whether it can be regarded
as being compliant it being amg's desire
the notice should be can so as to give
the impression that it never existed
that is a
fors with the jurisdiction of the
employ and it's not a matter
today the ground ofal though was was
wrong to form the that the first FL May
used fir FL was unfe and the second
ground was that they it was safe prior
to that appeal that documentation
third responsible authorities accept
that
has against
those having the documentation
provided health and
safety
1974 were parents and then
with Ser uh dealing with sites and EV
very specific documents identifying the
specific R control measures that were
required that notice has not
about October
2023 since then there has been a further
two visit to the
pr was taking place in the 209 November
it was in an announced
inspection
doron's statements which will you will
high
difficul
noted on
arrival when went into the
E3 there was a steward with
concerns were expressed as to how
Communications could take place
between in an emergency
situation and not problems too because
in the ABS of working
radio
[Music]
EV there were traffic management
problems they were observed there are
photographs the road closures were not
being
Vehicles were parked where they
shouldn't have been Vehicles were
allowed into the closed area when they
shouldn't have been uh and there was
interaction between pedestrians and
individual in so far medical staff is
concerned prior to that
event it had been discovered because of
a complaint but one of the paramedics
being to was the subject of an
investigation
as and in those circumstances
taking that he would allow to work
premises he wased working those
premises in breach of that
undertaking uh and when challeng it was
suggested
iMed would have
left the inadequate position he was
eventually replaced it being suggested
it was safe for him to work because he
was working under
supervision on the first of December
there was a second visit again there was
problems with the
enforcements in relation to the engress
and of
people the failure to control vehicular
traffic again pedestrians and
traffic taxes were allowed to queue up
there were agressive
traive counil
offices
and the management of that
was it is suggested in
from difficulties of traffic management
is that the council a failure by the
council to engage
withg it is suggested that the council
um is operating in a way which is
discriminatory toward because it differs
from the way the council deals with
Manchester United because it suggested
that Manchester United is not
requ in place in
respect that is an in
assumtion manchest
United
they they do
payement thecil offic in cont
to what was also Illuminating was at
that meeting was Something Told
shine he asked for guidance by the
council
offic he said he needed that guidance
because he was heavly
Guided by seing management
as so the difference
between
is
quite well
set
SK when he
says that there is no working relation
between
and there isn't there hasn't been
since the enforcement history makes it
very
thatg drag to the position of
trying in Readiness for the
and they have
failed they are in effect seing to Agate
their
responsibilities to manage their
premises safely and effectively in a way
that the licensing objective and to
place those
responsibilities
on and the question is raised is why
have the responsible authorities not
agreed to
but there is
no two things Aris during the process of
these
conditions sub the first is statements
from and second thing that there have
been propos in which AMG sorted
to right conditions that their
responsibilities
Council Rel
to it
lidget to
do it is also the case that those who
seek to operate large scale
entertainment responsibility to do so in
circumstances where they manag them
properly under their own expense they
should not be a their
responsibilities to the council they
should be doing properly and we
have that they are and given latest
visits and given wealth
documentation has provided and given
them that they don't appear to be F
their own procedure seem to be a case
where to borrow a quote from
Al but that's a trouble with me I give
myself very good advice but i s thought
and that is a view responsible
authority of the
way has been condu their
responsibil view is that we can ask all
sorts of things when they get them but
we don't have any confid to deal with so
the issue is from our point of
view what are you do what can you do you
have a
range you could say depending on what
you think that there should
be um you could suspend license for
three months we don't see any Merit in
that these enforement proceedings a
visit be going on months you could
change the designated supervis but that
was
done what else you well it's to you um
but in the absence of being
satisfied this particular langage has
changed
respons
will improv anytime
soon
maybe must
consider so those are the
OB your position has Chang from
the no
not so
say proceeding with at condition in
detail the instructions that I have are
that there is no
confidence that
the
LIC and that there has been a tendency
to try and Abate their respons
ities to
the responsible authorities and is not
very right is not the responsible
[Music]
[Applause]
author
yeah
so what's the way through in in in terms
of resolving the
issu thealony
structal structural
calculations no
long where there is
concern facilities to control the
capacity of each of the individual are
the issue
is
time feed we get back we
considerer the
council there is no there is no
me meeting of mind is
obviously challenging I mean the issues
to do with the
traffic there's a traffic management
plan that closure order is apparently
very very
informal it's
for Council can enforce cannot
operate and it is matter for
what the council to do it respons to
[Music]
do
result so
[Music]
there
raed
Rel
[Music]
instructed
again Cho to operate
and it is
responsibility there is a distinction
where
criticism
theyave
United Manchester United do have
process they G through
process
SC so I mean
[Music]
are I mean mention issue with the hot
water
believe yeah as far as I'm aware
um the other issues the issues are
[Music]
the they must somewhere where
um The View that has to be taken is
enough enough and pres looking at feed
Rel position is we
I don't see
Bri because on the oneg say we're
looking forward to constru relationship
the opp and yet on the
[Music]
other so apart from
the the the objective yet to be agree
you're still saying there basically aist
list of documents to do with the
management plan of the venue
we re otherc
onay we have received
documents they
have as good as they could be as good as
they should be um I
know and safety consultant that has been
um commissioned by AMG
different I mean don't how you Enis
these matters be Sol is a strong
chance
concerned
rision basas basis
it position local
authori responsible auth we are and it's
difficult to see um without there being
some retrenchment from
[Music]
direct sure that's listed
[Applause]
ination want to correct me I'm not not
aware of you you having the power to put
matters off
to direct should
be
[Music]
ask
thank
you so you have been given a very large
amount of paper quite a big glor paper
came in on Thursday and Friday can I
just
put can I just check you've got from us
two bundles of documents one big one one
smaller
one well there two there's two s
arguments and then there should have
been a big bundle of documents which
came about two weeks ago and then a
smaller bundle responded to what the
council submitted on Thursday and Friday
we sced around and we put together a
small on
[Music]
Friday
right
well
um very kind
and granted Mr C an adjournment on
October and the reason for that was that
when this review started here got to say
the council looking for
conditions and then two days before the
hearing
October he got information that actually
the council was going to seek a ration
this LIC so he wanted to submit evidence
well Mr PRI has now come with a very
large team people CL of 92 but there
about 11 I think and we a very large
amount of evidential material which I
hope you found helpful what I haven't
heard is any
thoro attempt on behalf of the council
to look at that evidence and appraise it
and say whether and how it meets the
council's concerns and where are gaps
remaining and so example even just the
question about whether the Upper Floor
is safe wasn't stated it had to be said
in answer to a question by you which is
fairly foundamental driver for this
review um so I'm not going to take you
through every bit of I am going to ask
you to hear from some of the main
Witnesses who can give you their expert
appraisal how these premises oper these
I'm going to ask you to reach the
conclusion that they operate very well
indeed uh and uh some conditions have
being proposed by various of these
authorities my client has agreed most of
them there's some which don't work in
the individuals case so we've um put
forward a modestly lended list of
conditions we prepared a table so that
officers could just write their views on
it so that you can see where there
actually are differences that went in I
think about five weeks ago being chased
on a number of occasions we've had no
reply at all um so we are trying to see
whether we can narrow the issues but
unfortunately we haven't had the kind of
Engagement which would enable the issues
to be narrowed for you so what you've
got is two very large piles of paper
which you're going to need to make
findings on without much assistance as
to how that paper has narrowed the
issues
so I'm going to say a few words by way
of opening and then I'm going to
introduce you to my client's main
Witnesses um the ones you're going to
hear from I don't mean to embarrass them
but between them they've got about 150
years of regulatory experience between
you which I hope tells you that my
client has taken this case extremely
seriously this is a very unusual
position for my client to be involved in
Mr hland here uh has been involved in
the operation of premises including in
this city for 30 years this is the first
time ever you have to have given
evidence to a sub committee this is not
something finds itself in
regularly uh if at times I I appear to
be a little critical in what I say um
please accept from me that that is not
intended to me that my client doesn't
care about its
responsibilities or doesn't care about
its relationships with authorities it
cares deeply about its licensing
responsibilities and it cares deeply
about its relationships with authorities
relationship with authority by the way
is not to agregate responsibility it's
to work in Partnership because
authorities have powers premises
operators have powers their own premises
and certainly premises is the only way
to get to be in conversation and that's
my does it all over the country so let
me tell you just a little bit about
AMG uh it's a highly experienced
operator of music venues it
specializes it has 18 venues in the
major UK towns and cities including some
very famous ones uh it has two in
Greater Manchester this venue and also
the O2 rits in Whitworth Street which
it's operated for a number of years I
can tell you that over the past 15 years
AMG venues have hosted over 45 th000
shows and they've hosted events
attracting over 39 million
customers now this isn't just a numbers
game that means that my client has to
deal with a very large number of
promoters of artists who got their own
requirements companies corporates of
health and safety teams from Stadium
tours etc etc if my client did not run
safe venu news it wouldn't have it has
that
reputation in
2022 coming out of
co uh my client ran over 3,000
shows and admitted over 3 million people
so it
knows it attracts the full range of
musical Talent it hases very much about
Rising artists local and Grassroots
artists all all the way up to Major
International stars who are drawn by the
reputational benefit of appearing as an
AMG venue the professionalism of amg's
management and also the enthusiastic
knowledgeable audiences which AMG has
built up across the land including in
Manchester it has a very strong safety
record underpinned by Advanced health
and safety
systems documented risk
assessments oversight of venues by the
visual managers I think we brought along
the visual manager today a hand up there
who reports in turn to the highly
expiations manager through health and
safety training venue managers and St
and the use of reputable exterior
contractors and these include security
contractors transport contractors
welfare and medical
contractors and
corresponding with that safety record is
a strong regulatory
record my client in all that time 45,000
shows has never been
prosecuted cautioned for any criminal
events we licensing or health and safety
or otherwise it is Bri to
say that tragically this last year it
experienced its first ever review
following a fatal crushing incident in
London and that resulted in AMG
offering and the subcommittee accepting
further conditions on its that's how the
matter came to be dealt with with that
exception it never been reviewed until
now here in
traford one important part of the reason
for that is that it documents and
operates Safe Systems it trains and
supervisors it stuff appropriately and
it devotes appropriate resources to the
operation of its events very large
numbers of people are there to ensure
the licensing objectives are promoted or
bringing their expertise and it does an
awful lot more than that it does
National Training sessions it has
independent health and safety scrutiny
and so on and so forth what you would
expect of the large corporate operating
in this field the other important part
of that is that it set store by working
in constructive Partnerships to devide
Solutions where necessary and to
continue to systems to protect workers
visitors and local residents all my
venes in urb centers so for example my
Cent meets pretty much monthly local
police what security threat issues
you're which are rising and so on and in
that way there's information and
everybody gets now Victoria will need no
intruction of this region and it's one
of the most sought after industrial
spaces in the UK home Le his company
renovation in his hands started in
2009 and then from
2012 the venue hosted a number of events
including the well-known Warehouse
project now found in May Depo opposite
Manchester as I've said my client first
became involved in
2018 when it took on a lease of the
premises from Mr Co compy I have to tell
you that my client is highly committed
to this venue not just because of it's
long Le but because it is thinks it's a
glory it views it as one of its Flagship
venues in the
UK the capacity points out a rather
different order to World TR it ises
three and a half thousand people for
concerts in the main
ordertorium otherwise shed a and 5,400
when the whole building and all of its
sheds are brought into operation for
club nights I
think speaking in general terms there
about 80 events 90 events a year now my
client is moving firmly towards concerts
as its main stay you might expect at
maximum 10 plus nights
during are people that come to see a
concert Joy themselves
and my client has attracted leading
artists and events for this space uh
including this last year the BBC 6 music
festival uh which is one of BBC's I
think main three public music events
during the course of the year and also
the radar Festival an International
Festival of progressive music so this is
very much in keeping with standing
uh of this area as a receptor of Leading
Edge
culture it also hosts conferences
private and Commercial events dinners
award shows and so forth and has been
pleased to host Manchester United Audi
Coca-Cola Microsoft eBay Mar Spencers
New Look jaguar and Land Rover and all
of those events team and all of those
blue chip corporates are very concerned
to come into save venues which are
properly managed as indeed my client's
venue is and it's right to say that its
customers spend within the L
economy Hotel football is there Hilton
is there is there the hotels are always
well used and my client has events on
and local restaurant and Club trade also
benefits out from the influx into Trav
leaving C tr's reputation as a place
where
culture happens and is
encouraged and what is it record
day uh five years in well I've set that
out in my first
skeleton in the series of proposition
but let me just go through this because
we've submitted a huge amount of
information in case
because we responding to some
quite rigorous
criticism my client has held this
license for five years it has put on
about
shows that excludes the private events
those are just
shows and as a m has admitted
680,000 ticketed customers
over that whole
period there has been no
allegation of aach
condition so it's with an element of
curiosity when I hear Mr
Parry put on comp he always compes
and has five years and despite
unannounced inspection after unannounced
inspection in
paration has been made in this
Cas police or res or C or anyone else
preaches its
conditions there is no complaint by
greater Manchester police about any
crime disorder in the premises my client
doesn't suffer crime disorder
Le than holy negligible it has a
perfectly cordial relationship with
police meet time
time make everyone's
happy this isn't a place where you need
concern yourself with some sort of
there is no representation by any local
resident or local
business big ones or little ones in the
case of
businesses how you know
newarts opposite no
representation there has been
no Public Safety
incident my client
has teams and teams of people who make
sure that everybody is safe that
thees they
are
there will be 60 FL
staff
stff and 10 management
staff there'll be 60 security
staff and six year compact security who
really security company they called
approved contract suppliers which mean
that they hold gold standard creditation
and secur the industry Authority
they know exactly what they're doing
everyone
their there
are no fewer than eight medical
staff with extremely well equipped
medical position dogs and incubation all
all things that You' expect much larg
and qualified medical
staff and there are also from this
Autumn there are welfare St acept
welfare are say somebody comes in and
panics something of that doesn't
feel being I don't know there's a
welfare space right there started up by
company
Rel large number of people consider
there's also the medical team is in the
welf room in case welf issue medic issue
and
then there's some allegation which has
been repeated today despite the fact
that we so about topic the medal is
to it's about as far from the side door
of the
if
that and it's always been there so
why these allegations are made they're
noted have the actuality it's always
been place but the medical team that
going to sit there in standard isolation
one of them is in the welfare area in
case they pick up something which might
in fact be a medical issue and two of
them are in the pit looking out onto the
event to see if they can spot something
might this is an extremely well run
operation I told you about 60 security
staff they're not just employes gag
they' got jobs emplo to particular
places and um know they manage
queue they manage to
search they are there managing oversight
of the bars they're in the pits looking
out on the crowd they're Manning the
Staffing say the staing fire exit doors
when they need to they'll be up on the
balcony to spot anything is under
happening there they're staring up
control room looking at CCTV so this is
a properly proved
operation of security and then at the
end they're also out there helping to
Mar people away from premises to ensure
the traffic walk road is kept safe
supporting the traffic management staff
of whom there's five um there was some
fairly remarkable submission just
made Mak no progress on stuff mean after
discussions with your Highway people in
2021 2022 my client hired a hugely
traffic management company who was out
there rain or shine on every event night
the and two drugs and cones and signage
and so forth um supervising a managed
road closure in traffic W road so that
people can get safely which they do
246 sorry 680,000 of them since 2018
there's never been we've checked there's
never been a road traffic collision on
traff
warad
danger completely non bu R but anyway
since 2022 spring of 2022 we've had this
traffic management plan in place
Etc and subcontractors both Etc and
their subract here today
Mr made stat
piday say manage it it's fine we do it
dynamically because you always to
actually going on and people get away
from the premises safy I'll come back
deal
with a little bit later if you add all
those people together we've got
[Music]
about 143 people there to make sure that
the 3 and half concerts I say so the
idea that my Cent is Som Miss negligent
complacent arrogant is
absolutely untrue and un it lots of
res people any time that there's no
crimeal disorder there's no health and
safety ins there's no new
and there's no complaint about
protection of children from time so just
to complete the list there's been no
substantiated nuisance complaint there's
been no incident or complaint regarding
protection of children from harm there's
been no road traffic
accident at the
premises the main driver of this review
which seem to hasten both the
prohibition notice and the
review um seem to be allegation that the
first
floor 9% of which had been there since
1927 when the building was built and
it's supported by a conspicuously strong
system of Steel joers and
bracers uh seem be alligation balls un
safe there was a balcony which was built
in about
2012 um and can look at that and
photographs of it in the bundle you can
see
security that is built and the answer to
that main driver of this review that my
client is running some unsafe first
FL um the answer to that is it is safe
and it always was
safe that is
accept to be accept because two separate
firms of structural engineers said it's
perfectly safe um it would take um
660 not into K but
structural it would easily
take on
busy process making sure that more than
660 people have um and it's actually in
your papers we created the process
off um and I can take you to it if be
there's a a process for
St
Bott
um during my always risk assess
everything
um
during the course of
2023 as a
company I think probably driven from
above I find part of group structure
which includes um some much larger
concerns the move was to formalize and
unify how event management planning
happened within the
group and there was a huge project
during 2023 my client worked to move
from risk
assessing to risk assessing in order to
inform the EV event management
plan you'll be familiar you got to Big
stadi here but when it comes to
concerts
LC there would be event management big
events that is standard the venu that is
not standard it's extremely unusual
because imag event management for every
single event my client moves to have an
event management plan at every single
event that is underpinned
by a risk
assessment uh officers have said that
they want to do risk assessment to
follow a scored
Matrix where
every risk every risk is rated for
likelihood one to5 and severity one to5
it's not necessary it's one of the
wayal sector being
very operator made the risk assessment
into the format has wanted and I've now
shown you the event management that's in
your papers and it's a detailed plan and
it appends the risk assessment and 31
other documents give everything you
could think of
counterterrorism uh security thearch
medical welfare Etc and officers have
seen that
and my has written number of times to
say we just check that you're really
happy with the event management
plan and they haven't had a
reply so my
argument presumptuous seems extraordin
this is what this Cas is about we
haven't and here are at 11:30 second
day
two
months well we think it's really good we
think it's Leading Edge National CL
event management plan and the beautiful
thing about the event management plan is
that we'll put it on shared drive so
your officers want to know you'll send
any send several months ahead
EV
they
EXA to read it take time to read it but
it's there and they can take fact that
it's there and so I have
to express a feeling
of but
curiosity how is it that we can
demonstrate we are
and yet we have an opening that says
we're so unom so resistant to Assistance
or compliance that our license need to
disaar we just canot understand
it
so with all of that know the record on
breaches of conditions the record on
safety crime disorder M protection of
children from harm the resolution of the
issue in relation to
the resolution of the issue relation to
manag I think offic one two
places they're not doing it exactly like
said they going to do it do for example
the risk assessment assess the risk of
something in relationship Ser low to
medium the security briefing assed as
medium to high the good re the later
document and was treated as a criticism
my Cent would take that as a
demonstration that they dynamically risk
assessing the security would breef his
medium to high and they were carrying
out a full sege so the reason for
criticism is simply unknowable my client
is genuinely trying to make sure that
all risks are covered on but now you
know that that there's no breach of
condition no harmful licensing
objectives uh good event management
planning an excellent St plus contract
is in place this suggestion that the
only thing what will do for this hugely
important cultural venue for TR is
revocation is is completely without
foundation without any
foundation and even leaving aside that
this is a first review of the
license um when you get this much paper
in a
it's usually
because dis in issues stabing whatever
it
and and it's so the idea ofation is I'm
not going to
say Cent comes
here to say the least surprise
to find itself involved in no few and
four litigious disputes with your
officers this two prohibition
notices sorry two Improvement notices
and prohibition
no for
the off a one
Department that is for
more than the whole of the rest of its
estate put
together um my Cent operates in cities
which are renowned as CID for their
attention to Regulatory Compliance and
in all of them I tell a similar story
about how
I doesn't find itself in litigation I
can promise you sir that traffic is a
very important feis for my client which
is a very responsible operator it is not
decided to exercise special complacency
in traffic there's no company policy it
says let's just get
traic and even if it wanted to and it
thought it could get away with it it
couldn't afford to because it wouldn't
attract artists of any sort
of unsafe they demand high standards and
a good reputation
um and as you can see my Cent find on
series of issues you got in front you 15
witness statements with 70
exhibits well as I say sometimes you do
get when there's been endless
crime that sort of thing but for a
cultural view without any record part
the licensing objectives it does suggest
that partnership
and a senior level intervention is
required for it to be installed and
indeed to get us many tsunami wi
statements on Thursday and Friday last
week opening up a new
front in relation to traffic
management which was put in place in
2022 with the cooperation of the high
people no visits since then no concerns
expressed
and then
theing suddenly we can't manage
traffic this is a really good good
example of where we need to have way of
doing business and of course the licing
sube is an ideal to say come on sit down
there
issues as soon as it does that I'm sure
will fall in no resistance might find
whatsoever highly responsible operator
values Parts it's not going to throw
obligations on tra that's not
all but Trafford things that they want
to go through of course go through what
necessary and in fact we've got some
really good examples this traed officers
wanted queuing off the pavement
AR P happens on Pavements all over the
country but it didn't it took it took it
quite a while because it didn't own the
car Manchester United own the car E3 and
it took quite a while for my client to
do the agreements with Manchester United
to allow use and then what my C do on
Match Disney the whole match it
could system one and
then side the it took some time but it
worked and it's been in place since
March
2022 quite having
dec3 is not entirely clear to me traffic
wanted a traffic management plan wanted
to control the traffic War Road so my
client hired a really good company Etc
pays them n on six figures a year to
have traffic
management every
event so people can get away safely to
say all
SE people come out of the venue and
you've got come out venue like that you
got
war and then you've got exchange
key the left and
bigun that from The
Pedestrian
that's give you
very
you
my is perfectly Happ do whatever having
heard nothing since spring of 2022 said
over
there2 part of that traffic management
plan included tra traffic highways
applying to a traffic restriction order
so that those closures would be and
legal I'm not criticizing I don't know
why they didn't but they didn't and last
week my call
from should we proceed
this de3 so that might help but in fact
the reality of it is that it's an
informal closure managed by hugely
reputable operators and experienced
operators who do nothing else but
closures and it's managed um some
criticisms have been made oh but we saw
the bus go
along yeah go on the GMP sorry on man
transport website you find that the
route x50 proceeds along Road my has no
power to start a public service vehicle
traveling on its designated route and so
the bus is held it's Marshal it's walk
through
walk and then on it way it said all that
my
client doesn't require happiness to get
into that
are to move
on tell taxi to move on Taxi tell to
get my tell where to go there's no
traffic version um it said well um car
is there's 150
there stop getting to their all these
things are the sort traffic
about from my VI lot
ofal
ofure stop lores speeding along stop
cars
speeding and to make
away place so we uh we took the queuing
off the payment as requested by TR we
put in place a traffic management plan
as requested by Trafford we produced
several structural surveys to
demonstrate the structural Integrity of
first FLW as required by tra I take the
history want it's probably a bit boring
but
my 2018 hir very reputable Structural
Engineers to give the hold and they were
perly content with the whole building
then when tra officers raised this in
last February my client sent capacity
calculations they want more so it then
sent structural surveying work not a
full report snipp it they wanted more so
in August my client hired very reputable
Bo King who said look we we've done some
work on this now we're perf happy to to
use full report in due course but my
client unilaterally said if you're
concerned about this reduce capacity up
25 until we've got the full structural
survey and then sent through um Bo done
three pieces of work long long pie work
which is all in the bundle the
structural survey capacity Plus a
dynamic frequency in case of upstairs
Shook and also there's report from the
landlords Harry sea all show that it's
all actually fine so again request from
Trav response from my
client um they wanted
a a event specific risk assessment which
they' got want event management plan
which they' got and so on so this
suggestion my CL has drag to the table
recant reluctant it's just un true um
you you will not find a more willing
partner
in the music
world an to
an protect customers they have a
wonderful nice
out now let's just look very briefly at
the main issues
raised firstly there was
this now just for you in a little what
used to happen in the warehouse project
going back to
2012 is that the que started up at the
main Jun overhanging the canal on that
busy road and then people were fed in
through gates near to the busy
Junction and down through the premises
will eventually be a hotel into the main
easterly door of the
warehouse and I think from anotal was a
bit chaotic with a lot of pressure
people up on that Junction overhanging I
think
made their life but it wasn't a great
way of doing things by the time my
cent no to use the two
Ware onad near West
warehouses it had the agreement I think
of one stage highways to con off the
layby so to provide separation between
people and cars it's not a
[Music]
busy doesn't it isn't an arterial in
sense all are um but officers didn't
like it they wanted us to change it
changed it and been changed in Spring of
2022 there are no issues at all um the
warehouse
holds on con night three and
obviously go all ride at once but car
park easily holds 25,000
people so there's no real Prospect we're
going to end up with few spilling out if
it did happen for a few minutes while we
process people we manage it if my Cent
notices a buildup crows in the they're
Allied up and down if my client notices
that's it's kind of he'll just open the
doors ear it's got St there to do to do
it processing people through um so
that's resolved it's gone it's off the
table we can talk about 2019 if we need
to we are here in December
2023 the structural first floor I think
I dealt
with risk
assess
um one of the things which one of the
features I think of this
case is that it may just be a sort of
style um
but tables don't seem to be place of
meeting what what seems to happen is
that there are large unannounced
inspections the large number of officers
you come in and they tend to come in
just as to Show's beginning so all these
people head of security had medical the
manager gctb they've all got jobs to do
but officers are there say we need to
see this we need to see that and it
immediately of course puts my clients
Under Pressure because they're trying to
that moment serve two different
objectives and there are D GRS
where do really
good detail how complicated operation
best to do it
table
you well we saw this could you explain
how that happened we weren't sure about
this have you thought about improving ET
that's
relationship but on this occasion in
August
2023 um officers came in they wanted to
see the risk assessment there a lot of
risk assessments my client was trying to
help them and was printing stuff off and
they said well their parking was running
out so they just took a file and it
wasn't a complete file my C's risk
assessment and
then improv
noce which is then mentioned in this
case well my client has given this um to
misser and she has looked at the entire
site of risk
assessments including the gaps which
would have appear pred officers because
they didn't
ask um and she said it's a
perfectly risk assessment options
however you don't need to get into that
because my client now has the event
management plan which has been sent
through two months
ago um and has had no comments received
upon it despite many chases well my kind
would preferred officers if they liked
it say we like
it say about this say that they haven't
really said
anything my takes that of criticism as a
tation there were very subsidiary
matters um which were
raised
in February
2023 when officers came in with water
system wasn't functioning as well as it
could have been when my client knew that
there was some intermittent of system
and my client had already placed um an
order for all of the new equipment which
is due to arrive I think the foll day
day after it was well aware that there
was an issue and then it was said the
medical room was dirty um it was a final
floor of yard to get to it would have
had years footprints on it my
simply it was also said there was
[Applause]
[Music]
AAL
and again they were also required to do
pre during and post de CLE of the
medical room they
got there are a number of historical
matters and I'm going to just take my
life with my
hands
everything is covered in
the Mr H's first statement answers
everything been said that there's one
exhibit not
in5
my insistence we wrote down every one of
the criticisms in this
review I'm Sor
my let's just deal with traffic for a
moment and as I've said in September
2021 there were expressed concerns about
traffic Management on the road at that
point you'll remember there queing on
pap and that seemed to be the biggest
issue for traff officers that they were
wor
speeding
I'm there's cars going and what about
hostile vehicle
litigation and so my client at expense
to itself
uncomplainingly started negotiating
Manchester United to get cubes off the
road and that led
to screen of 2022 hes off the road Etc
engaged all their personnel to do a
managed
closure there was then a
visit in February of 2023 by officers no
concerns was then a visit in August of
2023 no concerns
expressed no meetings highways not
looking for on no concerns
highways no concerns me no one saying
you're dangerous system out there so
there out there spring summer
winter
two visits and th
Friday together video link to is deaden
it and some
Stills which I've taken instructions of
for example all the tax moving into
the on
traffic just not how it
happen anyway very
nice and we tried to deal with
this uh in another statement Mr which
exhibited email
Mr
um I think it's fair to say that given
the objectives of that traffic closure
it work really well these people are
walking away from
venue crossing the road safely and cars
not along the road in either direction
there be no accidents there be no near
misses no interventions no high rate
interventions
outside my client voes is the
world and the world has its
challenges
so one challenge
is that illegal Street Traders set up on
the pav outside my Cent's premises to
trading standards matter my client is
not to address illegal
street
the second
TR and if you happen to support
Manchester
United you happen to go to a you SE this
problem which is that organized crime
GS set
ups
illegal around they even signs
say oh official parking it's not even
official
parking and ifate Commercial
operators my client does not have power
to tell them what to do it's problem
that my do best to
manage it can't goest
people
my
Cent
turn up
to take Manchester City
C that's the way they go
and my client can make sure that priv
Vehicles can't into man it does it
allows but it cannot tell
Ubers towards that
fun really happy to manage that as best
they can looked at by Shield very
experience work my Cent is really happy
to sit down with police and
highways and take another look at Howa
happens around this
ven unique traic in relation to lar
venes my Cent is a mids Vue all they
need to do is say so and my
to attention and we work together this
is one area where I strongly
suggest given the lat of the evidence
given one person minutes you
can't Bott today we have time to deal
with I've had five minutes talking to um
Etc and Mr Haywood I haven't spoken to
your highways offices Etc this is just
come up to L but it doesn't need you to
micro what my client does there needs to
be a boundary
to
system there's
aary where the operator takes a sort of
ownership and my client ownership is
basically traic from
Junction
really this is
issue all you
people
so resolution
today at the set all the
authorities all of them suggested
updating
conditions so when Mr H got a call
duw on the 8 of
September
sayda we these
conditions my was very happy to engage
in that conversation it was content to
agree most of the conditions which
suggested in some respects there was a
language which needed
tightening um and in some respects was
language and we suggested an amend five
weeks ago and we've chased since
everybody so people could just go into a
word doc and say yeah happy not happy
with that because and you'll find that
table on page3
wish sat in his study and produced this
table and you'll see as you go down
it the First Column is tra's original
propos conditions the second
isg agreement revision and the third is
AMG
explanation so just to take I'm just
looking at random I look at the third
page of this table there's one about
public
probability there's
another that's all the contents of it
but then there's another which says we
should produce a medical ambulance and
first aid plan and we just suggested the
mod has change to a medical and first
aid plan fire safety plan
changey plan
the details of things like electrical
installations and so forth and my Cent
just refed the plan around what it does
which is risk assess EV man I'm not sure
it could have just been agreed Etc and
therefore we're not all so all I can do
is to give you the assurance that this
has been looked at
prior and of course my client and also
by me there's nothing in our proposal
which
is contains anything
secretive we're just trying to make set
of conditions practicable for
the that my actually work with having
circumstances
you
could I'm
you explain
why so so that's all I want to say by
opening I just want
to just see the color of some of
my so I think the first person that
we're going to hear from is Mr Ian Smith
from shei
and just check page
numbers page
297 of the
supplemental 11
December good um Mr
Smith you
are Associates that
right and if we look
at your
background you retired from the Met
Police Superintendent with over 30 years
attempting service you were then Deputy
B
Commander
hington you with a strategic need for
licensing within the
Met
um
and oh I'm so
sorry can you introduce yourself I read
that completely
wrong for 1.5 isn't it sorry
for side inva officer I'm a m of the
security Institute in Li and since time
years cons company and licing consult um
we we prepared a 32 page report and I we
help if I just did a brief overview of
that
report so much your time so um our
instructions in terms of reference with
basically key documents V using to
support operation
in addition we would observe the Ingress
ESS and operational processes at the v
in addition we make
comiss so what we concentrated on we
made two visits
one one Friday 10th of November and one
on Saturday 11th November so event was a
non Manchester United match day the
other one
was the r behind that were concerned
about the clash between man united
holding their home game and the2 hosting
and events on that particular day just
to see if there were difficulties and
issues
arising um prior Toom we a number of key
documents for the Vue including the risk
assessments a number of this is in
section six of your documents you set
out the 30 or so documents that you
looked at that's correct that's on page
six and seven of our it's quite
sensive so in summary found these do be
thorough and fit for purpose we made
some small amend and some suggestions to
inove those
documents so on both of those we
deployed to the Jess coner with vacity
about 3,000 on boths how long did you
spend at the venue on each night eight
hours I mean there two of you yes we got
32 hours of AR on this operation okay
okay so on the Friday the 10th of
November that was the not United match
event we found the is good again the the
benefit now being able
to people away from
ra it's fair to make comment
that vulnerab from
vehicle conc again I feel that the venes
to into that
carate some of those
concerns so
um what we also found is that there was
a good use of the queing utiliz the
barriers and there an effective
sear interestingly enough the the search
engine was not condition of license but
again decided to produce that into their
operations
the again another positive we saw was
using the Medics researching areas so by
that people came with for
example they look exam
see
seity what we did observe which is more
of concern because Mr Co mentioned
already
the illegal Parking
Services illegal Street Traders an
illegal for hire we were counted on five
times ourselves during that night we
left in my opinion that's quite clear
organized which I'll cover further on
later one of the many issues contri
build
traff can't be resolved in my
professional
needs
um the the on both nights the the
illegal Parking Services continued again
Mr mention they professional fix
the official Park and
actually their website does indicate
that they
not again there's only so much they can
do um the this
on again for that night the Manchester
United was a temp tnp place again we
advised a slight change it was busy but
not chaotic most people were actually
left that 20 minutes certainly
Ober and I would go
fur
High
so for me the the challenge of the TMP
is the
ocg cars you've also got the add
parking opposite
again and taxes
tole pre-booking
with patients that may have a disability
so this a challenge
so again in my opinion there needs to be
a more strategic approach to managing
this by that I
mean the issues of the organized grle
stre TR all contribute issues and
challenges they can't Sol
that all these issues are contributing
to that parking and issues around
the
L so if IAL with the Man United match
this is before the V was
open this had no impact on the venue all
it wasn't open all the E3 was being used
on one side by Manchester United so in
they
split
so corporate to leave visitors going to
leave the game they half half and later
have the other half still their search
and they funn in through the
side so what was what was my observation
there was new TMP in place 75,000
people so where you have the tnp for
3,000 people coming along TR there is no
tnp so you got 75,000 people walking in
different
direction without
any which is is surprising a lot more
SC a small with 3,000 people can
event so but also what I would say is
I've been to many many sporting events
and this is a
Comm not everybody has a
t people just make their way way home to
the transport hubs using vehicles and
people are aware that even res know on
mat day you're going to have a high
density of people in the RO
and if you go anywhere UK this
happens again lond as go
to so the E for the match today was the
same as the previous day and again I
noticed um again rightly so about fast
moving
car September last
week so when we've conducted open source
checks unfor luxury now that access to
police databases so I'm relying upon
great Manchester police post in the
database for over a threee period in
that locality they've had zero positions
but 11 when you extend that paramet
further
TR so if it was an issue I would expect
there to be police being enforcement
campaign by the police I would certainly
expect the highway agency in respect to
traing car measures also expect that I
think when they did their enforc some
issues around
potential seen any
CCT time you were there did you see
vehicle speeding along no endangering
anybody no not all go back I said before
you got
people you've got high density people
difficult
to we didn't see thatly didn't see
people all both those
days um finally haven't received any
correspon or information that's come
from place this is an
issue you see certainly lots of
communication going back between VES and
the police and also the local
Authority vehicles and then address itly
whether they
have
Poss being put in certain Highway agency
if it was an issue again that's probably
Bing back the fact that they
have
dat
um the good two good point I should
mention is that
V profession purpose is reasonable it's
practicable again
some response to deployment plans and
some
ader
processes
lat so in in respect two things that I
thought very very good the show set
briefing by the staff that was excellent
and for me the indry stand very
[Music]
good it it was about how to St the show
sa his expectations dur show procedure
again
comp
comp so that was very good and I
[Music]
thought
lookity
very by they do so again that's positive
feed
again last the traffic
management busy not
chaotic we gave
some I think there needs to betico this
can't solve that problem on because
they've got no power to engage with
with
Traders tax is Ping up they the same
you CH manag so for me it means people
more strategic level dealing with all
the issues both the police local
authorities highways agency certainly
with the senior
manag this which is
resolvable the appetite to do to work
together that's what I think is of
part just just just go through piece by
piece arriv an
Ingress my C do what they be doing
absolutely yeah control of the bars yes
the security deployment on the site and
the way the security team works together
and it's deployed to specific tasks and
also with the levelis
well um
emptying the premises that process of
getting people out and in relation to
the management of the curage venue and
what's immediately outside getting
people away from the premes are you
cont I think impr if you
look I think that the traffic management
Pro on with all the agenes being
involved
I think I'm right saying is that even
thefor 10 days ago they
found yeah and again that's why you
neede involement Cann
do so what's your conclusion of
this my my own conclusion is that you've
got very well
and I rely on facts to to support the
fact that normally iend hearing it's nor
in relation because you've got highs of
crime not Prov anything
suggest ises at all and I think what we
left with is this traffic management
plan and how people get away
from the still cross me the fact that
you can allow 75,000 people to come down
traad no TMP
place there
people yeah there's a higher level of SC
smaller
V
300 and appreciate all these wider
issues around organized crime and Street
and all that did you feel that people
leaving the venue were
unsafe no I didn't because you've got
you've got people want to get away I
think the
wies in
isolation so we we hear from
from
and
um I think she's at page 105 of
theal
andig basic job
advate um you got a whole bunch of
letters up to your
name and you you've explained that
you've got 40 years experience in your
field and 10 years in eho 30 years in
commercial sector you were head of
safety for deons Argos home base and
habitat and John Lewis Mar and Spencer
yes that's correct and then since 2019
you've been an independent
consultant including girl Gardens
hundreds of enies across the country Le
City trust for over 20 years you were
chair of the British retail consulti
health and safety group you're a former
chair of the institution of
occupation occupational safety and
health iOS a retail and distribution
group you are former trustee and current
member of the Char insute environmental
health and safety advisory policy
advisory panel and you're the current
chair of their Enterprise Network and
you're an associate The Faculty of pro
I think um since the middle of this year
you are the independent chair of health
and safety committee and that is that
you got microphone by way I have sorry
oh that's good um and is that you've got
in that guys presuming you've got
oversight of the company's
processes
so thank you and you produced a
statement which runs
to 58 paragraphs I'm not going to ask
you to go through all those paragraphs
but let's just take this
in
stages I think your first
involvement was you were asked to
review the companies then process the
risk assessment of Victoria waree yes
around the actual date of the visit
specifically at the DAT that they
undertaken that right which I think was
the 20th W yes they had
taken um a file of documents yeah which
they treated as the entire compilation
of risk assessments yeah so you looked
into that indeed I went through all the
ments I went all the processes that were
operated by the ven in relation to event
um I took approximately three days to
actually go through all the
information um and I came to conclusion
that the risk assessments for suitable
in had the officers seen all the
documents comprising the company's risk
assessment or were their gaps
significant gaps that they haven't taken
those away um and there a number of
activities that run taken by
discuss so just in terms of that's a bit
unfortunate what would be better way
then to for information to be shared
around risk assessment so going forward
we have actually taken steps as AMG
actually taken steps to simplify that
process um what I would say is the venue
totally understood those risk
assessments were what they contained and
it was Dynamic a lot of it was going on
during the course of the event Etc what
we've done is we've taken steps or
they've taken steps to actually um make
it so that anybody long could understand
it right and that's the event management
plan that's the event management plan in
terms of the specific event and the
event risk assessment and also um risk
assessments around so we've pulled them
into a much easier for the offic to
understand what I would say is V did
understand it um but we want to
simplify sort of compilation where you
can look up in the index if you want to
know about intoxication or
counterterrorism who just go
depend not we put it into one document
and referred and gone off to other
documents we made it simp okay and the
health and safety risk assessment which
goes with that is in the form of Matrix
things score five we're not
scoring yes yeah okay
um so this is in the sense subcomittee
is concerned to know whether the process
of prevent planning risk assessment is
happening in Victoria warehouse and conf
way which keeps people safe is it
absolutely I say as you said in terms of
event management plan I've not actually
seen that being used been used to that
extent so this is goes above and
beyond and just in terms of going back
to the TR of AUST there not announc
inspection and officers are leaving with
insufficient understanding yeah of what
the process actually is what the
documents actually are what would what
would your advice be on that
well I think going forward there's
opportuni to have um planned meeting so
that everybody can get together and
actually they know what what they need
to see we can provide that information
to them um we are AMG are working to try
and build relationships with every
localy where we have a venue to try and
reach out to them ahead of any activity
so that we can provide that information
to them so that's actually
okay well you've been at this for lot of
years an expression was used here about
how something like that might be an
appucation
responsibility do you understand that
absolutely not it's basically um
engaging authorities and you know it's
definely not
application they've got powers
absolutely and then you have the
venue we need to make their life easy as
well so
I think that we help them to understand
what we do and going forward we
potentially
looking help that okay but in any case
just
case no absolutely not i' I've worked
with lots of different companies and I
have to say um I've definitely not found
that withg I can't say
okay right well I'm going to leave you
there and then I'm I was going to try
and hear from Mr for but I think it's
now conclusively agreed and accepted
that the first floor is structurally
safe I think we'll pass over you and um
maybe we should just hear briefly from
Mr hman
representing
management and Mr H I think you have
made two statements in this
case and the first of
them
was witness statement
dated 29th of November
2023 and it runs to 18 Pages I'm not
going to take you through the whole
thing but can you confirmed to me that
the entire contents of that statement
are true yes thank you and you
explained that you have been doing this
really for 30
years um from the shop floor basically
to managing premises for many many years
to being promoted to a division manager
and then to become the uh group of
operations manager AMG ultimately
responsible
to 18
venes can you just tell us
about's attitude first of all to help
safety Public
Safety just just
characterize do in terms of it resource
ter training terms caring
about
yes we
become people we invest in training
invest in processes we speak with
authorities speak we
understander people very serious
view
people obes
we all our train experience provide
training for all levels of
teams and is that career progression at
AMG starting off whatever you're doing
and then working up through the
management grades did people receiving
the training goes along yes absolutely
people experience on Ground events
people that work
in Warehouse the past experience of
tra understanding systems
systems that's about Staffing and we've
heard about the process of risk
assessment and event management planning
which was subject to an evolution in
2023 to make life easier for authorities
may want to look in what it is up to
tell me then about the kind of resource
you put towards these venues in terms of
contractors other people helping ven
well each venue has own security
contract own medical
provider of welfare systems Contra the
lar
ver we have a dedicated team of support
team office that all aspect of the
operation down we have five division
manag respons small
am management close contact regular
meetings um we we ask people to engage
we follow that
up and um that probably accounts for the
regulatory record which I um set set out
for in this case you also got traffic
management company yes is that something
you
expect pretty much UK only handful
ofar Place processes in
place majority of premes
vub in towns and City Cent
so talked a little bit about event
management planning and then when it
comes to the
night how do you know that the event is
going to run as planned and how are
issues discussed people justs on no we
we understand most of the shes that are
coming into the very well because
we venes going
or understand festivals that that so we
speak to venes we speak to FAL
organizers we very CL Rel so do full
onst and Auden that coming into each it
appropriately the V weeks
contract prev
weeks lels will discuss RIS
that's coming up to the event then on
the night of the event is is there we've
heard about the show stop which covers a
quite a long range of topics but is
there also securitying
security
[Music]
Department
5:00 people with the artists we
Willam
top we talked a little bit already about
deployment of security Vue every to
their place supervising their place we'
talked about crowd spotters we've talked
about people in the pit security medical
Etc um is there also somebody dedicated
to sitting on the CCTV system watching
what is actually happening that's
correct do
CCT
controller video controller as well who
will look at the
CCT identify areas of
concern through the security
networks sort of Hub on the radio system
and the CCTV system so the night goes
off hopefully peace I mean you haven't
had crime disorder Public Safety or
Child Protection issues public Nuance
issues but the the night goes off
hopefully nicely but then is there a
debrief at the end of the
[Music]
night so when you look at the operation
this venue are you are you losing sleep
at night about how Victoria
Ware not all
it's SEC operation it's l and location
actually helps it in manys because it's
by one car
theel chy about this how how much of
your time is now during these
proceedings Etc being spent on vior
Warehouse compared to the other 17
venues that you have um at the moment
moment Andor takes up all of my time and
I deal with issues
withfor
this this more than
all can you understand actually why that
is and so far as traffic is
concerned you
have um
employed uh C their contractor for a
traffic management which has been in
place in the spring of
2022 to your knowledge have there been
any concerns registered with the company
over the last 21 months about how that
was
work you've
heard organized crime groups and illegal
street phas and all that sort of stuff
um any fur what Mr Smith has have to say
about it what would your attitude be
just to having a meeting with the
relevant departments and GM to talk
through these
matters I think you did have a call last
week on highways when perh but they
haven't put in place
the um I mean there was talk in some of
the evidence we received I think on
Friday well it's supposed to be a
traffic closure but
saw 16 minutes somebody saw n Vehicles
Trav through it six and a bus Etc does
that surprise you it doesn't because the
major
risk
okay you're not sitting there thinking
our customers no because
[Music]
so uh it's all 59 paragraphs take all
day we're not going to um sh five of
your first statement is a sort of table
where you set out each of the
um we made and apply to them and then
you compile something a little bit hly
on Friday which deals with the
pr9 December and sh6 you you include an
email that Mak sense
to
observation of inform he's the one who's
actually there
doing main play that's probably all I
wish to say and maybe you have any
[Music]
questions
sois of cross
examination
[Music]
St
two different licenses operating here so
what's the arrang you with the land they
want to put on
something will Prov
they may betiz
their for the toac
stores
I so they're operating tobacco just to
be clear tobacco stour is the East to
the
end you can see got
[Music]
to
second Rel Manch
United are my instruction
well they don't have man
Rel where
very was
[Music]
by the time of July
2023 absolutely not I mean I wasn't
involved before ju important that that
the venues actually build further
relationships and that's what they're
doing and they actually does exist in
other areas Mr who knows about oper
acoss the
country um
R venes and
open so I directly deal
with
[Music]
myself Rel
I would welcome the chance to improve
the
relationships we are always available
for discussion meetings and since
2018 I was the divis manager responsible
for I have many which is very auor so um
Cly
Rel
traed
[Music]
terms